[Música]
cambiamos de era
nuestra existencia está amenazada
principalmente por nosotros
evolución como lo entendió darwin
significa que una especie se adapta al
entorno que cambia y que amenaza su vida
y hay riesgo hoy hay riesgo estamos
entrando a una nueva era que nos llevará
en muy poco tiempo a explotar asteroides
otros planetas a editar el adn de
nuestros defectos enfermedades y hasta
envejecimiento a regenerar ecosistemas
completos y crear vida en un mundo de
abundancia para todos esto es lo que
dice la ciencia la evidencia es
contundente y la pueden consultar con
autores como steven pinker en sus libros
de pedreño sabrán pero en light mente
now lo pueden confirmar en las
estadísticas dedo gordo enteira o lo
pueden profundizar en abundance de piro
y de amandi
sin embargo conforme se aceleran los
avances en ciencia y tecnología se están
acelerando también las tensiones de
nuestro ecosistema amenazando la
existencia de nuestra propia especie
para muestra pues con 1.019 en conjunto
con las epidemias y catástrofes
naturales que se han registrado con cada
vez más frecuencia e intensidad en las
últimas décadas
corremos riesgos si somos una especie
vulnerable frente a esto definitivamente
sí
necesitamos evolucionar y necesitamos
hacerlo ahora
hemos progresado mucho agresivos
incansables y como dice pinker cada vez
más humanos pero el momento crítico que
estamos atravesando exige otra cosa
tenemos que acelerar nuestra evolución
no solo para asegurar que la ciencia y
tecnología resuelva los cambios del
ecosistema sino especialmente para
evitar que nos destruyamos por nuestra
propia mano
el homo sapiens que nos puso donde
estamos hoy supo sobrevivir y dominar un
mundo de escasez
hoy estamos en otro lugar la desigualdad
la segregación y nuestra creciente
vulnerabilidad ya no son culpa de
nuestro ecosistema son cada vez más
provocados por nosotros mismos
no estamos avanza viendo tomar el
control de nuestro destino porque
estamos en un rumbo totalmente diferente
y acelerando una velocidad exponencial
como en un coche en una carretera que
sube a lo alto de noche en un peñasco
sin luces y con el acelerador a fondo
si no tomamos el control nos vamos a
morir
como evolucionar
hay mucha investigación sobre nuestra
evolución y nuestra propia intervención
en ella desde la genética biológica o la
intelectual
yo quiero hablarles de una evolución
cultural que se ha vuelto crítica para
nuestra supervivencia
se trata de conscientemente cambiar
creencias y hábitos especialmente
alrededor de nuestra productividad y de
nuestro valor en el mundo
hoy que nos enfrentamos al conil 19 nos
da angustia perder la vida que teníamos
el status quo pero aferramos a las
convenciones y evitar el cambio es lo
más peligroso que podemos hacer cuando
necesitamos evolucionar adaptarnos y
sobrevivir
a mí a los 48 años me cambió la vida de
rumbo me detectaron cáncer de mama fue
en una revisión de rutina como las que
me hacían cada seis meses la sorpresa
era un tumor de 7 centímetros de
diámetro que había crecido en mí durante
6 o 7 años ya resultó que mis revisiones
no habían servido de nada yo no tenía el
control como creí durante todo ese
tiempo tienes cáncer significó vas
camino a la muerte pero la angustia más
grande era esa falta de control nadie
nadie me podía asegurar que el protocolo
que quería practicar en mí
el protocolo convencional me iba a
salvar y vaciadas arriba de ese peñasco
acelerando a todo en él en esa
enfermedad y durante los siguientes
meses bueno quimioterapias radioterapias
a pesar de que era incierto todo el
mundo opinaba y todo el mundo creía que
lo mejor para mí para mi fortuna soy un
poco rebelde y me gusta la investigación
y estoy segura de que lo que me salvó y
devolvió a la salud fue mi insistencia
casi necedad en salirme de las
convenciones y entender tratar de
entender lo que el resto del mundo los
otros expertos otros científicos otros
investigadores y la inteligencia
colectiva consideraba más avanzado no se
imaginan la cantidad de soluciones
vanguardistas que encontré no hablo de
la charlatanería hablo de lo último en
ciencia y tecnología del futuro ante el
cambio de rumbo tomar el control es
importante
y hoy mi salud está mejor que cuando
tenía 40 años
también de impacto un equipo de
ingenieros quienes desde el 2003
preocupados auténticamente por la
humanidad y por supervivencia sabía que
el mundo iba a necesitar de energía y de
transportación que no contaminará así
que decidieron crear un auto y otras
soluciones de energía limpia solar
eléctrica para el futuro y considerando
tecnologías que estaban por nacer o que
podrían desarrollar ellos también en el
futuro
trabajaron para toda la humanidad y
trabajaron con todo el colectivo con
cualquiera que quisiera colaborar entre
más cabezas mejor compartiendo avances
aprendizajes y toda la tecnología creada
el primer test lab fue lanzado hasta el
2008 ese grupo de ingenieros ignoró todo
lo que se sabía sobre cómo fabricar cómo
hacer autos y trabajo desde el futuro
hoy en día estos autos circulan con
energía casi gratuita pagan un mínimo de
mantenimiento tienen el doble de vida
que un auto convencional y lo mejor
dejaron de contribuir al cambio
climático como dije la tecnología de
estos autos está disponible para que
cualquiera la copien la mejoren la haga
más accesible pero está ahí desde hace
13 años tardamos demasiado en sumarnos
al esfuerzo no pensamos no pensamos
cuando debimos en nuestro interés
colectivo ni consumidores ni industria
ni gobiernos
nadie apostó por nuestro futuro
preferimos aferrarnos a las convenciones
el resultado el resultado está en la
contaminación el cambio climático y
todos lo conocemos nos urge aprender de
los ingenieros de tesla nos urge
aprender a diseñar para las necesidades
colectivas del futuro contando con las
tecnologías más avanzadas y las que van
a venir las que no han llegado pero
están por llegar y dice la leyenda
urbana que el jefe de tesla insistió
hasta temperamentalmente en nunca
recurrir a lo convencional hizo muy bien
en insistir
la evolución que urge hoy entonces
la de una visión en futuro versus de la
presente y la convencional también está
en buscar el bien colectivo versus el
individual o el de unos cuantos
por otra parte también la generación
zeta
piensa en colectivo trabaja para el
futuro fíjense busquen los vean los
ellos nacieron en un mundo caótico y
amenazado para ellos la norma es
reconfigurar su realidad ha ayudado con
tecnología e instintivamente piensan en
el colectivo y en las comunidades en sus
comunidades estoy segura de que su
cultura es la que nos vas a dar son
diversos son inclusivos son comunitarios
creativos respetan y hacen respetar al
ecosistema entonces que ven los
ingenieros de tesla e intuye la
generación z para diseñar es el futuro
quiero insistir que es lo que tengo que
ver yo también para tomar el control y
evolucionar les compartiré unos bloques
de futuro para que con certidumbre
ustedes puedan visualizar su propia
evolución se vean en ese futuro
estos bloques de futuro cuentan con la
seguridad de los colectivos son más
inteligentes que un individuo por sí
mismo
quieren diversidad para sobrevivir
biológica intelectual genética o
cultural son más eficientes para generar
riqueza e igualdad a la vez sacan
provecho también de las tecnologías más
avanzadas las que vienen del futuro les
cuento
la primera trata de que todo será más
barato los costos de producción de
almacenamiento de logística y
transportación para disminuir de forma
drástica
cualquiera lo podrá hacer con
inversiones mínimas y altos estándares
de calidad
el acceso al mercado será también
sencillo y económico para cualquiera es
decir hacer publicidad vender tus
productos como los grandes es algo que
cualquiera vamos a poder hacer
segundo punto es que van a importar
mucho más muchísimo más todas las
personas y el planeta entonces veremos
que las producciones personalizadas y
las artesanales que cuidan de la gente y
que cuidan del ecosistema van a crecer
en valor al igual que también el trato
personal la atención personal la
creatividad y otras capacidades humanas
las que las que nos ayuden a hacer que
los demás disfruten las que también
podemos contribuir a que los demás se
sientan bien eso va a cobrar muy alto
valor
también va a crecer la conciencia
ambiental en todos nosotros por ello
también crecerán las ganas de comprar y
de consumir a favor de quienes realmente
trabajan por el ecosistema y por su
gente el tercer punto que les quiero
compartir es que la inteligencia
artificial nos va a simplificar mucho la
vida
muchas de nuestra data personal va a ser
privada la vamos a poder privatizar y
vamos a poder cobrar por ella cuando sea
data de toda nuestra comunidad todavía
más valiosa va a ser nuestro interés en
la humanidad y en el planeta nuestra
vigilancia nuestras ideas nuestra
colaboración nuestra participación van a
poder también generarnos riqueza
queda claro que no es necesario
aferrarnos al presente el mundo puede
continuar mejorando pero eso depende de
nosotros hoy estamos en el momento
crítico en el que tenemos que tomar el
control evolucionar conscientemente
diseñando desde ya nuestro futuro y
poniendo como prioridad absoluta a toda
la humanidad
muchas gracias